hi everyone
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and on behalf of yipsa the whitney
humanities center
and the department of germanic languages
and literatures at yale
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
here today to our benjamin and barbara
zucker lecture series
today's speaker alex ross a fellow
harvard 90 alum
has written about music for the new york
times the new republic
the london review of books among many
other publications
and he's been the music critic of the
new yorker magazine since the 1990s
alex has won a slew of major prizes
including the macarthur genius grant
his first book the rest is noise
listening to the 20th century was
published in 2007
and won the national book critic circle
award was a finalist
for the pulitzer and was named one of
the 10 best books of the year by the new
york times
his second book listen to this a
collection of his essays was published
in 2010
and his new book uh right here wagnerism
art and politics in the shadow of music
from which his talk
today is drawn was published last year
this book took more than a decade of
work
but it's really amazing that it didn't
take even longer
uh alex has seemingly tracked down every
reference to wagner in literature art
dance philosophy you name it over the
past 150 years
and in every major european language
as he puts it on page 15 the book has
socialist wagner feminist wagner gay
wagner black wagner
et cetera it's all there and analyzed
with a keen sensitivity to the way that
artistic forms produce political and
social meaning
the book is encyclopedic but also
incredibly engaging
and entertaining to read it gives a
grand overview of modern
and modernist culture through the lens
of wagner
so let me just say a word about how
things are going to work
today uh alex is going to talk for about
30 or 35 minutes
and then i'll lead a discussion with him
please submit
uh questions uh to me using the q
a button at the bottom of your screen
and you can send questions at any time
even during the talk please though don't
use the chat feature or don't raise your
hand we can't see
or hear you and we'll end promptly at
six
so now i will turn it over to alex his
title today
is the unforgiven wagner jews and
anti-semitism thank you so much maury
uh for a very kind introduction
and it is wonderful to be
invited to this distinguished series
to talk about a very charged and
difficult question which is the composer
regard wagner's relationship with
jewishness with anti-semitism
with the ideology of hate
that underpinned the the nazi
regime uh with the holocaust itself
wagner
is part of these stories uh
to a very disturbing extent but at the
same time he
is a gigantic figure in
cultural history who
has touched upon and has
touched so many different worlds
so many different people of variegated
backgrounds in a way that it becomes
i think risky uh to
to categorize uh
wagner uh purely as
as being aligned with one
ideological strain or another one
political strain
uh or another um and
the mission that i undertook with this
book
was to give as expansive and perhaps as
contradictory a picture of this
phenomenon of
wagnerism wagner's influence
outside of music on the arts on
literature
on intellectual life and philosophy and
of course on politics as well
uh to give us as rich
and ambiguous uh a picture
and really i hope as faithful
as representative a picture of that
influence as i could um
to counteract to some degree
the the more limiting perspective
uh that so many people have on wagner
today which is to equate him
entirely uh with nazi germany entirely
with anti-semite and anti-semitism and
this is really the one
thing that people now know uh uh about
wagner is that he was hitler's
favorite composer um and
while that is true and while in no way
do i want to
push that aspect of the wagner narrative
to the side it becomes more and more
central as the book goes on i do want to
to give the the rest of the picture uh
and to and to show
how how extraordinarily
uh widespread wagner's influence was
at the turn of the last century uh
including his effect on
jews on african americans
on gay people on feminists
on on far left-wing figures uh
communists anarchists sort of all across
the political spectrum
all across the cultural spectrum and
then to ask
how was it that wagner's image became
more and more confined uh
by the darker side of his legacy
and i want to make very clear i do i
think this is a sort of
unpleasant accident that happened to him
it is something that he brought on
himself
and the superb formulation that
i found on the writings of thomas mann
which really i think gets to the heart
of the problem that we're facing with
foreigner
is that wagner thomas man once said
wagner was a uh a passionate
and devoted uh
follower or admirer of wagner who was
also at the same time deeply skeptical
of
of wagner i had this this enormous
ambivalence
uh toward wagner um in a way that i
personally
find uh to be a model as
as someone who also listens
with great admiration uh to tuvakra's
music and also with a great deal of
doubt
um uh anyway what what mon said was that
wagner lent himself to his own
misuse um and so i think that's that's
quite an elegant formulation that on the
one hand captures the extent of which
fogner was
manipulated exploited distorted
um in nazi germany especially but the
same time he was involved
uh in that process and his anti-semitism
was absolutely of course at the core
of the uh the the role
that he played in uh
subsequent events uh the the the
the means by which he became uh such a
dark and menacing figure uh in so many
people's minds
now there's a there's a slew of very
complicated issues
uh to be confronted here which i have
little hope of
covering in any detail um in half an
hour
uh but i thought i could sort of give a
a very quick
overview uh of of some of the issues
sort of
lay out the territory um and then really
invite
a conversation on on any points that
that uh arrest people's attention or or
raise questions or or objections
and just to continue this conversation
which is which is so important
and you know the thing that i would say
about
wagner and the questions
that hang over wagner is that this is a
very very
old conversation it's been going on for
a very long time
there's nothing new about it i was
actually a little bit amused
in recent years especially as
questions were increasingly being asked
about famous artists especially in the
sort of popular world and the metoo
movement and
and uh quote-unquote cancel culture and
everything else
so people were asking me was are you are
you worried
about wagner's you've written this big
book about uh vodka
and you know now sort of this this kind
of figures
is inviting more scrutiny um and of
course
uh you know it's certainly not the case
that
wagner just up until recent years has
been beloved
and revered and then suddenly people are
asking questions about him
you know the trouble with wagner began
in the 1850s if already in the 1850s
people are asking is wagner too horrible
uh for us to to listen to his music does
it have anything
to do with him um and yet somehow he is
still here
um and so there's something uh about his
work that that compels
attention and will not go away i think
precisely for that reason
i think it's so valuable for for
us to continue looking at wagner and
even using
this endless debate over wagner as a
model
for how we deal with other troubling
figures in our cultural history
uh because you know especially in recent
decades
uh a very sophisticated methodology has
emerged
for analyzing fogness anti-semitism for
analyzing the impact on his works
and then for dealing with sort of how we
look at the works how they are staged uh
in the opera house
um and ways in which we can we can uh
uh isolate and accentuate those
questions not to sort of brush them
aside
uh and so there's there's something in
this in this uh
wagner endless factory controversy uh i
think that is
that is edifying uh uh as we
gaze with a more skeptical
eye um at the the the heritage
of of western civilization which has
sort of so many
uh troubling questions behind it in in
so many ways
so to go back more or less to the
beginning um
the trouble started in 1850 when uh
wagner published an essay in the
distinguished magazine neuetz
shift for musique founded by robert
schumann
titled das udentum inder music
jewishness in music
this was not out of the blue it was part
of an ongoing debate that had been
taking place in that publication
and and other musical publications about
jewish composers and especially about uh
meyer beer who had achieved and then
still
uh held enormous fame uh uh as
as an upper composer um and there was a
a camp of younger german
composers as well as
music historians and critics
who were trying to combat this
influence of my beer and established
space
for the radical new uh so-called new
german school of
wagner and list and so wagner
contributed to this debate
a little of the vocabulary of this essay
was new
um this idea central to the essay that
um jewish people are somehow alien
to german musical culture to sort of
musical
cultural european musical culture in
general
uh that it's that it's somehow they
betray their otherness
uh as they attempt to master
uh musical speech this was not a new
uh argument there was something new
about the sheer force the violence
of wagner's language and wagner was a
violent writer
he was insistent he endlessly repeated
his
slogans and and his and his uh
uh uh as the german word is his
buzzwords
he was very good at coining these
buzzwords and and and
and and slogans and he would just sort
of pound away
and so there's there's an insistence of
violence uh
in this essay which which contributed uh
in some way i think to the
radicalization of anti-semitism
in german discourse at the middle
of the 19th century um the essay wasn't
noticed it was talked about and actually
within a few years
um i should have mentioned that it was
published anonymously
under a pseudonym but wagner's
authorship
became known uh and was actually
discussed
in england by critics who were very
friendly to mendelssohn's music in
particular
and who took great offense at wagner's
critique of
mendelssohn alongside meyer beer as a as
a as a jewish composer who was somehow
not truly
german or not sort of truly uh authentic
um
and and so this is really the beginning
of of the
of the critique uh of wagner's
anti-semitism as something
quite dangerous um in in cultural
discourse
uh but if within a few years uh
discussion had
deway and it really wasn't very widely
discussed to begin with this essay
and if wagner had left it at that i
think we would be looking at
all of these issues in a different way
but
he returned to the topic
of jewishness and particularly important
was his decision in 1869 to republish
this essay now under his own name very
widely distributed
in a way that called enormous attention
to it
and in the process he added an afterword
which
which extended uh the the attack
on uh jews and in quite nasty new ways
and his focus was
now not so much jewish composers but
jewish
music critics especially uh the critic
hans lick who had
uh emerged as his leading
skeptic and from then on
uh wagner was known
um as an anti-semite uh and has been
known
as such uh ever since yesterday was very
controversial there was a great
uh great deal of of um
uh uh distress uh over the essay
including uh
from among uh wagner's allies
uh just many people found it uh quite
um dismaying uh and and repulsive
uh there was also uh amusement uh over
this essay people
people found it ridiculous uh in in many
ways
uh to attack mendelssohn who really
assumed
uh such a major role in uh
posthumously it's this very grand status
um
in in the musical canon uh there
there were also sort of rumors uh
swirling
uh that wagner himself might be jewish
and that this was all some kind of
psychological implosion sort of taking
place
uh within him that he was becoming
hysterical on the subject of
of uh jews and i'll show
um on the screen share it here
a somewhat disturbing cartoon
such and uh the the title here is
darvanistische and victor
darwinian evolutionary theory um
and you can see pretty easily what's
what's happening here
uh an anti-semitic stereotype
uh is is evolving
into the figure of uh wagner
it is sort of an anti-semitic image that
also
attacks wagner's anti-semitism a rather
a rather troubling complex
phenomenon uh in itself um
and and so there there was this uh
this derivation of of wagner uh that was
seen uh
especially in vienna uh uh in at the
time
uh anti-semitism in 1869
uh had not achieved the the kind of
lethal political uh um
uh strength uh that would that it would
achieve and in a fairly short period of
time
especially especially going into the uh
1880s
and so there was a sense that that that
wagner's uh
version of anti-semitism was was not
quite aligned
uh with uh the political discourse
at the end of the 1860s but things
changed
after the crash of 1873 uh uh
anti-semitism uh uh really uh gathered
strength
um as a way of shifting blame
onto uh onto jews uh various other
forces have contributed to this um
this gathering uh intensity of
anti-anti-semitism
and the shift uh from
a more religiously or economically
based uh form of
anti-jewishness and i'm sure you've
discussed this kind of shift often
in this series toward this
pseudo-scientific biologically
defined notion
of jewish otherness of genetic
otherness which of course would become
the foundation of elimination as
anti-semitism
um in in the in the 20th century
uh this this idea that there was
something uh inerratically different
about jewish people that no degree
of uh uh
or conversion would address now a very
big question
in the discussion of agnes anti-semitism
is
did he himself complete this transition
uh uh from the from the older
uh form of anti-semitism uh to the newer
one and of course it has to be stressed
that the
older form of anti-semitism was by no
means innocuous
and uh thousands millions of people
suffered
and died uh under the
force of that version of anti-semitism
but it is nonetheless an important
question you know did wagner
himself uh undergo completed that
evolution
my feeling is that he that he didn't
quite uh you can certainly have a sense
of reading uh uh
das eugene and her music that's that
he's
he seems to be uh seeing
jews as innately other and
and no matter how how hard they try they
cannot
master the the language of german art
german music
and there's sort of something in them
which cannot be overcome
um and that is a sort of troubling early
indicator of that kind of
biological mentality but then uh
still in his later writings which are
full of
uh ghastly
from gobino and other racial uh thinkers
still
um there's this this sense the
suggestion that he throws out that
somehow there could be this
this transfiguration sort of
transformation that he
that he says would would raise even the
lowest
uh races uh upward uh
uh under the under the uh
blessed umbrella of of uh the sort of
spiritual
emanation of of a pure christian idea
the kind of emanation that one
might find uh at byroid in the
freshwheel house a bit by right uh
at performances of of parsifal uh and
you know this is not um
a very generous concession on on
wagner's part by any means
um but i think there there is a sense
that there's uh that he
he doesn't quite go all the way in terms
of this this sort of movement toward the
uh
to the biological anti-semitism and of
course there's the fact that he had many
jews
uh around him in in byroid and this gets
into
another issue uh of of his own personal
relationships
with jews um which are very complicated
uh uh uh and and sort of ultimately
hard to make sense of in in many ways
uh the the his jewish
friends and especially subordinates sort
of helpers
underwent a fair amount of humiliation
um in his presence uh but at the same
time there
there was a genuine friendship or sort
of fondness on
on wagner's part and no one was
compelling him
uh to to you know uh uh
uh undertake these uh relationships
there's something very complicated going
on uh sort of
some of this this sort of need to kind
of
have jews around him but also to to
control them or to sort of put them in
subordinate
uh positions um uh uh
strange dark psychological questions
uh with with wagner uh
jews were an obsession a lifelong
obsession that he could never let go of
um and and that sort of at times seemed
to sort of
dominate uh his his uh consciousness
uh and and he believed that ultimately
uh jews were going to be victorious
um uh and and that sort of
perhaps he felt that when one had he
himself had to submit
in some ways to to jewish presence and
to sort of sort of control it as much as
he could on
on his own sort of territory it's it's
difficult to speculate uh
dangerous to speculate exactly what was
going on uh but
it was there's there's something
different about there's something
singular about it
as against uh so much of the of the uh
anti-semitism that you find um in
in uh germany and austria other european
countries
in this period another
great question which arises a question
for which i honestly do not have
a fixed answer
is can one detect anti-semitism in the
works themselves
uh and uh there's been
a great deal of writing great deal of of
uh powerful and
intelligent scholarship uh on the
question of characters like
alberich and mima
the dwarves the conniving dwarves in the
ring
beckmesser the conniving
meistersinger uh uh america a
musical judge really sort of a a
metaphor for for music critic um in uh
de meistersinger
um perhaps klingzor
the evil sorcerer in parsifal certainly
the the figure of khundry the mysterious
eternal wanderer
um in in parsifal are these
are these jewish figures um very early
on there was
there was uh open speculation on this
point and actually there are protests
and early performances of meistersinger
because jewish opera goers
felt that feared that beckmasson was
going to turn out to be
a a jewish
uh stereotype uh somehow that that idea
did not take hold even though it was
it was sort of in the in the public
arena and
and sort of after those early
performances it's very difficult to find
commentary excuse me commentary
meister's language which brings up
this this jewish beckmesser issue sort
of either in in
the sort of jewish world or in the kind
of uh anti-semitic
press and commentary even right into the
nazi period
you simply don't find it uh the scholar
david dennis made a very very thorough
search
uh for such discussions of beckmesser
could not find them
in the case of albrecht and mima you do
see
mentions of the idea including from none
other than gustav mahler
that these are jewish caricatures of a
sort
but they were not terribly widespread
this was not kind of one of the dominant
lenses through which people viewed uh
the work of wagner it's really only in
the post-world war ii era the
post-holocaust era
that the the question of of jewishness
in the wagner operas has come to the
fore
uh the great philosopher teredor adorno
was one of the first to
advance this idea when he said all of
the outcasts in wagner's
work uh are our jews um
and then uh as i mentioned a number of
uh significant scholars uh
have have taken up this issue in recent
decades the question remains
unsettled uh it's a very powerful and
plausible
idea uh um but because there's no
evidence
that that wagner intended it uh and
wagner was not the kind of person who
who
kept his intentions to himself uh we we
sort of have to assume that this was
either a
secretive uh or even a kind of
unconscious
intention on on his part which which may
be so i think there's
there is something there but i find it
very difficult to to pin down
uh and and to be so absolutely concerned
about uh and i
i'm hesitant when people sort of take it
as sort of absolutely obvious and proven
uh that the the wagner operas are
anti-semitic but they contain
anti-semitic uh
caricatures i think that's going uh too
far
um and in terms of wagner's relationship
with nazism i don't think this is
something that i'm going to sort of go
into
uh in any detail because this is sort of
a huge question uh in and of itself
um but i think it's worth noting that in
terms of the particular
um rhetoric of
wagner's anti-semitism
it was not one of the primary sources on
which the nazis
drew uh for their kind of
anti-semitic uh uh sort of sort of
anthologies of kind of sort of
anti-semitic
writings jewishness of music would be
there uh goebbels
uh would quote one of the one of the
late essays uh
on uh occasion wagner saying that
that the the jews are the uh
plastic demon of the downfall of mankind
whatever that means exactly um hitler
never
quoted wagner on the subject of jesus he
never made any mention of hogan's
anti-semitism
uh if he undoubtedly knew that wagner
was anti-semitic he undoubtedly
uh had read the essay but he didn't find
it useful
uh to quote wagner on these points and
and i think the reason for that
is sort of surprising uh
sort of sense that in in nazi germany uh
wagner is not a a sort of titan
of of anti-semitic thought uh is that
that
his writing is strange confusing
contradictory
uh uh bewildering and sort of lacking
uh in in the kind of uh uh
correctness clarity uh that the did you
find and sort of anti-semitic writing of
a
of a later period um and uh it was
it was more useful vodka was more useful
to the nazis as this
grand cultural figurehead who seemed in
some way or another to anticipate
uh uh nazi germany to to sort of heralds
uh the the sort of hyper nationalist
nazi german state
uh sort of rather than a sort of more
precise uh pre precursor um
uh in particularly uh with respect to
anti-semitic uh
ideology there were some nazis who who
disliked wagner who found him um sort of
an inauthentic
anti-semite that found him decadent
um questionable uh on on various grounds
and
in previous periods there were a number
of anti-semites uh including
drewing and and paul de la garda who
cannot abide wagner
uh and found him to be uh repulsive and
and
sort of useless to uh their movement um
and so um by saying all this i i'm not
trying to separate
wagner uh from the history of uh
anti-semitism
uh he is there he plays an important
role um
but i think it's it's a it's a slightly
more marginal position
than a kind of typical uh short
presentation of
the matter would have you think that's
that sort of
uh wagner was hitler's favorite composer
uh
wagner uh sort of dictated uh
anti-semitism to uh hitler that he was
sort of an absolutely
formative presence um i think to sort of
to sort of assign too much
responsibility to wagner
uh is to let everyone else off the hook
uh in a way
and uh uh you know the the roots of
anti-semitism go very very deep
back centuries not just in german
culture and history but european culture
and history christian
uh christian uh history uh and around
the world
um and so wagner plays a role but uh not
quite as large a role
as uh i think some would have you think
um
the the last matter that i want to touch
on before uh
taking up any of your questions is in a
way the most interesting one
and the one that i spent the most time
on in the book which is jewish
fagnerites there were great many of them
not just those
who were directly around wagner um
in by right and as many other places
that he lived throughout his life
um but in the audience
uh among some of the most vociferous
enthusiastic
uh wagner fans um
and uh in later generations uh
uh through especially with the fantasy
sacrament period a
great many uh uh enthusiasts
uh not necessarily worshipers um
but but enthusiasts people who took
voguers seriously uh and found him
um inspiring or or sort of thought
provoking one way or another one of them
was terrible herzl
as i talk about uh in the book um and a
sort of remarkable
moment in the history of jewish
wagnerism is when herzl was in paris in
1896
writing uh darujin shots uh the
the the um the founding document
of the the zionist state the prospectus
of the zionist
state and at the same time tan hoiser
wagner's chanhoiser is playing at the
opera
in paris and herzl goes to see it
every time it's staged throughout its
run
and he says in his diary that
only on the nights when the when the
opera was not performed
did he lack inspiration lack conviction
for what he was doing for what he was
writing so there's a sense in which by
his own testimony
uh the music of tanheuser is
emboldening uh is empowering
herzl as he works and this is something
that we we
find very often at the turn of the
century
uh sort of throughout the late 19th
century into the early 20th century
especially younger people who go to
wagner
and feel what
w e b du another uh wagnerian
enthusiast called a movement of power a
sense of movement of power
within uh the spectator and a sense of
visions
of future possibility uh
future greatness sort of a feeling that
that one's ambitions are mirrored back
to oneself in more heightened form uh
as one one listens uh
to wagner and sees um wagner
and of course this mechanism can take a
much darker form
adolf hitler was exactly one of those
young people who felt
vague uh feelings of of future greatness
when he first started seeing
wagner operas in lintz but nonetheless
it's just a very wide spread from allah
and you find it with jewish fagging
rights and
and there isn't it isn't necessarily a
case of sort of the
the tortured or self-hating
jew uh it's been a lot of discourse
about
jewish self-hatred and a lot of uh
critiques
of the idea of uh jewish self-hatred uh
back and forth obviously wagner is is a
kind of
very promising territory in which to
pursue that theme and and
uh you do find a number of jews
who are very conservative who are
seeking to sort of assimilate themselves
completely who are disgusted by their
jewishness and want to somehow erase it
uh from their being and listening to
wagner becoming absorbed in wagner
is is part of that that mechanism of
sort of transforming themselves and
there's the
very uh dark story of the philosopher
otto weininger
uh who uh killed himself at a very young
age after writing what would become the
best-selling
uh tracked uh sex and character uh
racist
and and misogynist uh document of
of uh just startling strangeness
as we revisit it now he was also gay
um and and so this the phenomenon of the
self-hating jewish gognite is real and
actually
novelists and playwrights uh made fun of
of such a figure uh you find it in uh uh
uh carl sternheim and and schnitzeler
and some others
but then you have others who who were
not in a sort of state of
psychological uh agony and torment as
they listen to wager herzl certainly
seems
to be one of those of course there are
questions with herself about his
relationship with with uh eastern
european
uh jewishness and and his his urge to
sort of distance himself
uh from sort of certain forms of jewish
culture
yes but but i don't think anyone can
realistically describe
herzl as a self-hating jew um and
and and again sort of wagner was was uh
was he didn't seem to view wagner purely
as an anti-semite even as he was very
aware of
of agnes anti-semitism was a separation
that he could make in his mind
you find that with a number of other uh
jewish uh
rights and so this this is something
where i think we need to
look at the past especially with
a certain compassion uh
and a certain sophistication and and not
with a kind of extreme uh
self-righteous judgmentalism in the in
the
introduction of the book i i mentioned
the late critic
michael andre bernstein and his idea of
back shadowing
this idea that we evaluate the the
literature
of the uh pre-holocaust era and he was
talking specifically about jewish
literature in this case you know
uh through the lens of what came after
and and judging uh sort of figures of
this period
uh by you know whether or not they they
were
uh sensitive to rising anti-semitism or
whether they were oblivious to it and
and and so i think in the same way when
we look at
excuse me jewish uh wagnerism uh we need
to see as many varieties
and we need to realize that that that no
one or almost no one had any idea of
what was
what was coming and anti-semitism was
simply not
one of the one of the really defining uh
characteristics that the people would
would name uh attached to wagner
um uh in that period it was something a
lot of people were embarrassed by and
just would sort of prefer not to
not to talk about um it was very
important and it was very it was very
important in
in um uh the radical uh anti-semitic uh
circles um but with this with this book
i i'm essentially
presenting a vast and unresolved
question
of of you know what do we do with this
with this
uh titanic and troubling figure and and
his legacy
and and the sort of the all the
contradictory aspects of his legacy
and uh wagner and jews and anti-semitism
is is really the most uh obvious
uh uh uh case study uh
of of wagner's questionableness
of this sort of problematic nature but
there are many it takes many
many other forms um and i think there
there is a reason why factor is still
with this
um and what i end up saying at the end
of the book is is that
a kind of demystification takes place
um with with wagner no one can really
no one who's sensible and rational can
no longer put
wagner on some kind of uh pedestal and
sort of uh worship him
uh and sort of treat him as sort of a
pure emanation of
of a of a higher sphere we cannot forget
the history we cannot forget the context
but i think that's very healthy uh to to
always
sort of uh treat art as a historical
and human phenomenon and not to separate
it uh and not to uh
not so sort of elevate it and abstract
it uh and i think in our own culture in
american culture
we have problems with with our our our
veneration
of certain cultural figures uh a
veneration of our own
popular culture which we tend to think
of as pure and innocent
and sort of coming up from from the sort
of people
uh and and and sort of combating the
elite and
and and uh aristocracy and
and and sort of power and so on and so
forth but in fact there are deep deep
troubling questions
uh about our own cultural legacy and
the the sort of uh uh idea that i place
at the end of the book
is especially that that we as americans
uh have a great deal to learn from the
case of vag the famous case of wagner
as we look at ourselves uh and as we
look at
our our own uh problematic uh cultural
inheritance uh so on that point i will
uh come to an end um and
we'd be happy to okay fields
any and all questions it's vagner no
one's gonna have any questions
exactly no there are a lot of questions
already so um
i will try to um synthesize them and
um that was fantastic so thank you um so
much for that
i think you really gave us a lot to
think about and a great way to kind of
you know think about the the question
the problem
um of wagner so to start out i think
um can you say a little bit more about
the context
for the essay for the 1850 uh
das eudentum in their music essay so
why exactly did he have it in for meyer
beer i mean
meyer beer was nice to him in a lot of
ways like where
where was all this hatred coming from
you know i sort of skipped over the
the question of the origins of fogner's
anti-semitism before 1850 um
and it was sort of creeping uh to the
forefront
i think in the in the 1840s you know
there was also there was a lot of
anti-semitism on the left
and so wagner was a part of the left in
the 1840s and participated in the
revolutions of 1848
uh and had to leave germany in 1849 and
spent more than a decade in exile
um and uh as he was
aligned with with sort of democratic
uh ideas and sort of revolutionary ideas
at the same time he was
picking up anti-semitism from figures on
the left and of course we have the
uh the uh the issue of karl marx's
own essay on the jewish question the far
less
radical kind of anti uh jewish uh
language that you find there
so it was circulating it was like that
may have been sort of some of the
contexts in which
uh wagner was was first picking up this
discourse but then it was fused with his
personal obsessions
and resentments and so this is where my
beer comes into the picture
he left germany in 1849 shortly after
uh he saw maya beer mario basila prophet
in paris and
it was a huge success and he was enraged
and i think the sort of contrast between
meyer beer's ongoing
uh success as a german composer who had
settled in
in paris um and his own
uh failure and and sort of outcast
outsider status uh set off some kind of
some kind of rage uh in him uh i think
so i
would say that but the sort of
anti-semitism was already becoming part
of his discourse but sort of is
that that point that kind of jealousy uh
it's sort of
which became um uh radicalized but it
wasn't just about
meyer beer he just fell into a
psychological habit of blaming
jews scapegoating jews for his own
setbacks which are so often created by
his own
profligacy and and combativeness and
sort of general sort of
messiness uh in terms of how he dealt
with the world
uh he would he would find a way to to
blame uh
jews for those uh setbacks and this
became a recurring
uh kind of psychological uh obsession so
it was kind of a mix of these sort of
environmental forces kind of working
around him
and his own sort of uh
compulsion uh personal compulsion uh
coming to the fore and it's that
compulsion
which sort of which gives it
that essay and sort of all the
subsequent sort of
writings on jews it's what makes them so
disturbing uh
because it's it's it's not a theory
it's not an ideological ideology it's
it's a it's a passion
uh this is something that comes from
very deep within him and he confessed
that in a letter to list
you know it's it's vital to him he needs
he needs this hatred
um it fuels him uh and you find this in
other artistic figures
uh with when anti-semitism comes to the
fore you find it in ts eliot
uh it's very disturbing to see
anti-semitism becoming part of the
creative process
um yeah i mean uh
you know you also sort of you know so it
seems to me like
you know that there's this phenomenon
here of a kind of relation to capitalism
the jews are kind of representing this
sort of
relation to capitalism that's inspiring
a lot of
intense emotions not just in him but you
know in in
other people too including a certain
kind of ambivalence too so
they're kind of desiring this sort of
new relationship to the market
at the same time that they're sort of
hating that and themselves so a few
a few questions about the essay itself
so
um someone asked whether isn't it true
that he
um gives some praise for i'll maybe ask
these three questions together and you
can
you know answer them uh if you want so
isn't it true that he gives some
praise for jewish virtuosic
instrumentalists
at the same time as he um
you know uh heaps invective on composers
like
meyer beer and although he doesn't name
them i don't think my memory is he
doesn't name
meyer beer but he doesn't yeah um which
is
sort of all the more cowardly that he
wrote this anonymous essay attacking my
beer without naming my bear but everyone
knew exactly who
who i was talking about and then so
isn't it true that he has some
admiration for
for performers mildly i mean i mean
virtuosity is a charged word
you know it can become sort of near
virtuosity kind of mere
mechanical brilliance which is soulless
uh you know
he said the same thing about italian
opera there's this sort of brilliant
display that's that's
that's meaningless um and you know
covers up
kind of you know cultural vacancy
um and it's not kind of the true hearty
voice of of the folk um
it's it's sort of this this sort of
aristocratic
frippery um and so yeah he has this sort
of mild
mild praise but i wouldn't put sort of
too much emphasis on that you know he
also
he also praises to a degree burner and
heiner
really uh for being so scathing
toward themselves uh sort of becoming
models
of jewish self-hatred almost and so
that's a
that's another uh you know and he and he
did i mean he'd
he never bring himself to fully praise
heine but he took enormous amounts from
from hainan sort of elements so many
elements of that of the early operas
flying dutchman and townhart in
particular
uh uh come from from haina and i think
there was uh
i think the essay is is trying to sound
like haina in some way and is sort of
attempting to
to sort of model itself on this on this
uh brilliant polemic
uh that the taina and verna both
practiced
um and that he just falls short because
it's just not funny
um i mean it's not just not funny
because of everything that came after
it's just not
it's not it's not good comic writing by
any standard
um and it's just it's relentless and
it's and it's and it's
kind of plotting and ponderous and and
uh
uh and so it's uh but i think there was
some emulation
hidden emulation there so you know in
the essay
he says not only the jews are alien to
german culture but he also implies that
they're
incapable of producing real art right
that they can only ever
imitate or kind of parody and you know
so there's a question
um about whether you know that's that's
definitely a trope that you see in later
anti-semites
so like you know i'm thinking of someone
like dramaal you know at the end of the
19th century
um and certainly you know into the 20s
so but is that do you know whether
that's
new with wagner is he that's not new i
mean uh franz brendell
uh the editor of the neue et cetera for
music uh had
had said the same thing in an earlier
essay
i think also ted or uliq another
especially character ulik
rather than brendel had said really made
the same
claim about jewish musicians jewish
composers
in in earlier essay that had set off
this debate
then there were there were there was
there was another critic ludwig bischoff
who was defending uh mendelssohn and and
my beer and saying this
this anti-jewishness is is ridiculous
and
and um uh instead of heading back and
that degree and so that's where
wagner stepped in um but no this this
point had already been made specifically
about
uh jewish composers but but wagner
fleshed it out certainly uh he went on
at greater length um and and he
that that vehemence that that
repetitiveness
uh kind of solidified this idea was no
longer something that had been thrown
out in passing
in the middle of this back and forth
debate uh
uh in fighting among kind of german
music critics and commentators
uh it became it's the essay was just
long enough that it became a statement
on its own um and people forgot about
the the
the context of the various other
politics back and forth especially when
it was republished
then all of that all that prior
discussion had had disappeared
and so so although i wouldn't say that
it was there's anything particularly
original
about the just purely the the content of
the claims
that vagra is making in terms of this
this
the the sweeping cultural attack
on jews as infiltrators as imposters
in in german culture the scale in which
he carried it out that was
that was yeah and he um you know quickly
there there's a question about like how
far he went
you know did he call for extermination i
know
cosima is is not is you know she even
goes
you know she goes pretty far too but how
far does his anti-semitism go
i think that evan claims that especially
the ending
of this essay uh where he calls for
their untagalang the undergone is a
complicated german word
uh going under is the little literal
translation but
it also means kind of downfall
destruction
but it could also be sort of a
philosophical idea of sort of this
this kind of downfall that that turns
into this transformation
hegel and sort of other sort of views
that concept this way it's sort of hard
to read
you know um and uh so it can be read
in several different ways um i think
in the context it seems as though wagner
is in fact talking about
not quite sort of assimilation but
this idea that he returns to is sort of
at the at the end in his later essays
some kind of
some kind of apocalyptic spiritual
transformation which would somehow just
solve this
this problem and it can it can seem
menacing
but i think to equate it with the
holocaust to equate it with
with a sort of uh genocidal program
is just makes no sense whatsoever
in this in this context and no one
treated it as change i find
nazi theorists that are citing the the
ending of
this essay um uh but it's chilling you
know just because it's because
the way it ends with this word which
sort of clangs
clangs out on the page um uh is
the vehemence of it is is disturbing uh
later you know it emerged in when
when kozuma's diaries were published
that he had made
uh uh he had joked about
uh the terrible um theater fire in in
vienna uh where hundreds of people died
including um many jews and he sort of uh
joked about it and and said something to
the effect of
uh uh all jews should be burned at a
performance of nathan the wise
you know an utterly horrible uh thing to
say
um but again to sort of go from there
to sort of he's plotting the holocaust i
think
is is to go too far um and so
there were violence i think violent
fantasies
and some violent thoughts um uh but
it it just in no way i think can you
really
uh collect these sort of scattered
utterances into
into a program of course this was a
remark that emerged in the 1970s and
sort of had nothing to do with
sort of earlier history so i i was
really fascinated by your discussion of
afrovognerism you know and this the
fascination of
prominent black intellectuals for wagner
especially w.e.b du bois who you you
know described
going to to by roy in 1936
and you know so can you say a little bit
more about
that and about and did do boys
like was he aware of the of wagner's
anti-semitism did he comment on it like
how did
how did yeah um yeah it's a fascinating
case and this sort of emerged as i was
working on this chapter of the book
where i talked about
wagner race and racism the sixth chapter
of the book it was it was originally
really going to be all about the jewish
question um
and i thought i'd mention uh uh
black faggorites as well because i was
aware of
uh dude's voice uh and his love of
wagner but then it sort of took on
greater weight for me as i as i explored
more of
of du bois and his commentary and
vlogger and as i found other figures
uh other black figures intellectuals and
artists who had a relationship
with with wagner um alan locke
um uh um um
um uh shirley graham who later married
uh du bois um uh langston hughes
uh was was very fond of tristan
ralph elson in in his youth uh listened
to wagner
and and so it was something of a motif
you know among them on sort of
uh black intellectuals uh of a certain
uh
generation and so i was curious about it
what did they find in
in wagner and then i discovered this
extraordinary figure of loranna aldridge
uh the contralto who was contracted to
sing at viroit
in 1896 she was the daughter of the
great black shakespearean actor
ira aldridge and despite the fact that
kozma was if anything more racist
um than uh her husband uh
uh she was going to sing one of the
valkyries in the ring of byroid in 1896
until she fell sick and i was able to
reconstruct
her story in a way that hadn't been done
uh before and so i began to feel that
this was actually
a bigger theme and should have a bigger
presence in this chapter but of course
du bois is at the heart of it
and really what's going on with dubois
is this a mechanism that i discussed
earlier
of a a figure
from another background not not a white
german
uh nonetheless finding inspiration
in wagner's mythic apparatus
and seeing how this
this brilliant modernization
of of myth that takes place in in in
wagner's operas
especially the ring could be emulated
and so it's about emulation and so what
he talks about with wagner is he sees
a sort of future great black art which
sort of uses
the mythic past uh uh especially sort of
you know african
myths and legends as wagner used nordic
and germanic uh legends
uh i wonder whether whether du bois
might have been
impressed by the film black panther um
in this in this regard because sort of
this is this is something of what's you
know
happening um uh in that case but uh in
any event
it was um it it was that it was
it was um i think there was also a
slightly kind of
insolent or defiant element to du bois
sort of
stepping in and saying this is mine you
know this this these masterpieces of of
white
western civilization also belong to me i
can take them i can make use of them
convert them to my own ends i think
that's something
also what's going on with herzl you know
um and
and and so there's a certain uh uh
defiance and pride and how he
takes hold of of wagner um and then this
extraordinary
story that appears in the souls of black
folk of the coming of john
very you know devoice didn't write that
much fiction
this is this is an extraordinary story
and the crucial scene in it is this
young black man
has gone to school and envisions his
sort of future
kind of progress in the world and
becoming educated and becoming sort of
it's a it's a it's a commentary on on
booker t
washington uh style kind of you know
black
improvement and sort of betterment and
then there's this catastrophe
or he's at a concert and uh
the usher taps him in the shoulder and
says he has to leave the white
woman sitting next to him has become
uncomfortable by his
presence then it turns out this woman is
with this
white childhood friend of his
the whole story sort of spirals toward
disaster but
the the as he's listening to the music
and it's wagner's
loving the preludes of the lord he has
this vision
of of some other worlds that could be
achieved that he could sort of step into
and it's denied to him
and at the end of the at the end of the
story he's about to be lynched
uh but the music is still running
through his head
um and i don't think du bois i mean
there's an ironic aspect of this
but there's also i think a sense and
when wagner
and dubois talks about wagner he talks
about he's he's transported by wagner
and he said there's
there's a vision here of something in
which one can believe and one can trust
that we can sort of carry with us um and
that can sort of inform our own
struggles uh toward toward a better uh
future and and so it's it's this is not
a sort of sardonic or sort of purely
ironic
uh uh sort of circumstance that he's
setting up it's just
it's a tragic it's a tragic one rather
than ironic but uh
it's quite powerful and it's just sort
of another just very surprising and
expected way in which
wagner plays in the culture of this
period the fantasy aqua
wow all right well we're out of time we
have you know 20 more
questions from the audience and i had 20
more so i feel like we could have gone
out for hours
but um i think we have to um
leave it there unfortunately and um
thank you so much for this it was really
i just thought um
you know uh fascinating and i recommend
to everyone
uh to get the book i also want to do a
pitch for our
last um uh program which is going to be
in two weeks it was going to be in one
week but it's actually going to be in
two weeks which is
a discussion with jake mccauley about
his new book the house of fragile things
um so mark your calendars for that and
again
thank you so much alex um i really
appreciate your coming
so and a pleasure thank you so much and
thank you to everyone in the audience